The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's
get started here.
Go ahead and take 10 more
seconds on the clicker
question, which probably looks
all too familiar at this
point, if you went to recitation
yesterday.
All right, and let's
see how we do here.
OK.
So, let's talk about this
for one second.
So what we're asking here, if we
can settle down and listen
up, is which equations can be
used if we're talking about
converting wavelength to
energy for an electron.
Remember, the key word
here is electron.
This might look familiar to the
first part of problem one
on the exam, and problem one on
the exam is what tended to
be the huge problem
on the exam.
I think over 2/3 of you decided
on the exam to use
this first equation, e equals
h c over wavelength.
So I just want to reiterate one
more time, why can we not
use this equation if we're
talking about an electron?
C. OK, good, good,
I'm hearing it.
So the answer is c.
What you need to do is you need
to ask yourself if you're
trying to convert from
wavelength to energy for an
electron, and you are tempted,
because we are all tempted to
use this equation, and if you
were tempted, say, does an
electron travel at the
speed of light?
And if the answer is no, an
electron does not travel at
the speed of light, light
travels at the speed of light,
then you want to stay away
from using this equation.
And I know how tempting it is to
do that, but we have other
equations we can use -- the
DeBroglie wavelength, and this
is just a combination of energy
equals 1/2 m v squared,
and the definition of momentum,
so we can combine
those things to get it.
You might be wondering why I'm
telling you this now, you've
already -- if you've lost
points on that, lost the
points on it, and what I'm
saying to you is if there are
parts of exam 1 that you did not
do well on, you will have
a chance to show us again that
you now understand that
material on the final.
One quarter of the final is
going to be exam 1 material,
and what that means is when we
look at your grade at the end
of the semester, and we take a
look at what you got on exam
1, and you're right at that
borderline, and we say well,
what happened, did they
understand more at the end of
the semester, did the
concepts kind of
solidify over the semester?
And if they did and if you
showed us that they did, then
you're going to get bumped up
into that next grade category.
So keep that in mind as you're
reviewing the exam, sometimes
if things don't go as well
as you want them to, the
temptation is just to put that
exam away forever and ever.
But the reality is that new
material builds on that
material, and specifically exam
1 a, question 1 a that
deals with converting
wavelength to
energy for an electron.
I really want you guys know this
and to understand it, so
I can guarantee you that you
will see this on the final.
Specifically, question
1, part a.
You will see something
very, very similar
to this on the final.
If you are thinking about 1
thing to go back and study on
exam 1, 1 a is a really
good choice for that.
This is important to me,
so you're going to
see it on the final.
So if you have friends that
aren't here, you might want to
mention it to them, or maybe
not, maybe this is your reward
for coming to class, which
is fine with me as well.
All right.
So I want to talk a little
bit about exam 1.
I know most you picked up your
examine in recitation.
If you didn't, any extra exams
can be picked up in the
Chemistry Education office,
that's room 2204.
So, the class average for the
exam was a 68%, which is
actually a strong, solid average
for an exam 1 grade in
the fall semester of 511-1.
What we typically see is
something right in this range,
either ranging from the 50's
for an exam 1 average to
occasionally getting into the
70's, but most commonly what
we've seen for exam 1 averages
is 60, 61 -- those low 60's.
So in many ways, seeing this 68
here, this is a great sign
that we are off to a good
start for this semester.
And I do want to address,
because I know many of you,
this is only your second exam
at MIT, and perhaps you've
never gotten an exam back that
didn't start with a 90 or
start with an 80 in terms
of the grades.
So one thing you need to keep in
mind is don't just look at
the number grade.
The reason that we give you
these letters grade categories
is that you can understand what
it actually means, what
your exam score actually says
in terms of how we perceive
you as understanding
the material.
So, for example, and this is the
same categories that were
shared in recitation, so I
apologize for repeating, but I
know sometimes when you get an
exam back, no more information
comes into your head except
obsessing over the exam, so
I'm just going to say it one
more time, and that is between
88 and 100, so that's 20% of
you got an A. This is just
absolutely fantastic, you really
nailed this very hard
material and these hard
questions on the exam where
you had to both use equations
and solve problems, but also
understand the concept in order
to get yourself started
on solving the problem.
The same with the B, the B range
was between 69 and 87 --
anywhere in between those
ranges, you've got a B, some
sort of B on the exam.
So again, if you're in the A or
the B category here, this
is really something to be proud
of, you really earned
these grades.
You know these exams, our 511-1
exams, we're not giving
you points here, there are no
give me, easy points, you
earned every single one
of these points.
So, A and B here, these are
refrigerator-worthy grades,
hang those up in your dorm.
This is something to
feel good about.
All right.
So, for those of you that got
between a 51 and a 68, this is
somewhere in the C range.
For some people, they feel
comfortable being in the C
range, other people really do
not like being in this range.
We understand that, there is
plenty of room up there with
the A's and the B's.
You are welcome to come up to
these higher ranges starting
with the next exam.
And what I want to tell you if
you are in the C range, and
this is not a place that you
want to be in, anyone that's
got below the class average,
so below a 68 -- or a 68 or
below, is eligible for free
tutoring, and I put the
website on the front
page of your notes.
This means you get a one-on-one
tutor paid for by
the Chemistry Department to
help you if it's concepts
you're not quite up on, if it's
exam strategy that you
need to work on more.
Whatever it is that you need
to work on, we want to help
you get there.
So, if you have a grade that
you're not happy with, that
you're feeling upset or
discouraged about, please, I'm
happy to talk to all of
you about your grades
individually.
You can come talk to me, bring
your exam, and we'll go over
what the strategy should
be in terms of you
succeeding on the next exam.
You can do the same thing with
all of your TAs are more than
happy to meet with each
and every one of you.
And then in addition to that, we
can set you up with a tutor
if you are in the C range
or below, in terms
of this first exam.
All right.
So 44 to 50, this is going
to be in the D range.
And then anything below
a 44 is going to be
failing on this exam.
And also keep in mind, for
those of you that are
freshman, you need at least
a C to pass the class.
So, if you did get a D or an F
on the first exam, you are
going to need to really evaluate
why that happened and
make some changes, and
we're absolutely here
to help you do that.
So the real key is identifying
where the problem is -- is it
with understanding the concepts,
are you in a study
group that's dragging you
along but you're not
understanding?
Do you kind of panic when
you get in the exam?
There are all sorts of scenarios
we can talk about
and we want to talk about
them with you.
Seriously, even if we had a huge
range in this exam from
17 to 100, if you're sitting
there and you're the 17, and
actually there's more than 1 so
don't feel alone, if you're
a 17 or you're a 20, it's not
time to give up, it's not time
to drop the class and
say I'm no good at
chemistry, I can't do this.
You still can, this is your
first couple of exams,
certainly your first in this
class, potentially one of your
first at MIT, so there's
tons of room to improve
from here on out.
This is only 100 points
out of 750.
So, the same thing goes if you
did really well, you still
have 650 other points that
you need to deal with.
So, make sure you don't just
rest on your high score from
this first exam.
So, OK, so that's pretty much
what I wanted to say about the
exam, and in terms of there's
tons of resources if things
didn't work out quite
as you wanted.
If you feel upset in any way,
please come and talk to me.
We want you to love chemistry
and feel good about your
ability to do it.
Nobody get into MIT by mistake,
so you all deserve to
be sitting here, and you all
can pass this class and do
well in it, so we can help you
get there no matter what.
You all absolutely
can do this.
And then one more time, to
reiterate, in case anyone
missed it, 1 a, make sure you
understand that, I feel like
that's important.
And actually all of 1 --
I really feel like the
photoelectric effect is
important for understanding all
of these energy concepts.
So, as you go on in this class,
make sure you don't go
on before you go back
and make sure you
understand that problem.
All right, so let's move on to
material for exam 2 now, and
we're already three lectures
into exam 2 material.
And I do want to say that in
terms of 511-1, what tends to
happen is the exam scores go up
and up and up, in terms of
as we go from exam 1, to
exam 2, to exam 3.
One of these reasons is we are
building on material, the
other reason is you'll be
shocked at how much better you
are at taking an exam just
a few weeks from now.
So this will be on, starting
with the Lewis structures, so
go back in your notes -- if this
doesn't sound familiar,
if you spent too much time -- or
not too much time, spent a
lot of time studying exam 1
and didn't move on here.
Today we're going to talk about
the breakdown of the
octet rule.
Cases where we don't have eight
electrons around our
Lewis structures, then
we'll move on to
talking about ionic bonds.
We had already talked about
covalent bonds, and then we
talked about Lewis structures,
which describe the electron
configuration in
covalent bonds.
So now let's think about the
other extreme of ionic bonds,
and then we'll talk about polar
covalent bonds to end,
if we get there or will start
with that in class on Monday.
Also, public service
announcement for all of you,
voter registration in
Massachusetts, which is where
we are, is on Monday, the
deadline if you want to
register to vote.
There's some websites up there
that can guide you through
registering and also can guide
you through, if you need an
absentee ballot for
your home state.
And I actually saw, and I saw
a 5.111 student manning,
there's some booths around MIT
that will register you or get
you an absentee ballot.
So, the deadline's coming soon,
so patriotic duty, I
need to remind you of that as
your chemistry teacher --
chemistry issues are important
in politics as well.
So make sure you get
registered to vote.
I just remembered one more
announcement, too, that I did
want to mention, some of you may
have friends in 511-2 and
have heard their class
average for exam 1.
And I want to tell you, this
happens every year, their
average was 15 points higher
than our average.
Last year, their average
was 15 points
higher than our average.
This is for exam 1.
This is what tends to happen
to 511-2 grades as
the exam goes on.
This is what happens to 511-1.
You guys are in a good spot.
Also, I want to point out that
what's not important is just
that number grade, but also the
letter that goes with it.
So, for example, if you got a 69
in this class on this exam,
that's a B minus.
If you got a 69 on your exam
in 511-2, that's a D, you
didn't pass the exam.
So keep that in mind when your
friend might have gotten a
higher number grade than you
and you know you understand
the similar material
just as well.
Similarly, an 80 in this class
on the exam was a B plus, a
very high B. An 80 in that class
is going to be a C. So,
just don't worry so much about
exactly where that average
lies, you really want to
think about what the
letter grade means.
OK, I've said enough.
I just --
I hate to see people
discouraged, and I know that a
few people have been feeling
discouraged, so that's my
long-winded explanation
of exam 1 grades.
All right.
So, let's move on with life
though, so talking about the
breakdown of the octet rule.
The first example where we're
going to see a breakdown is
any time we have an odd number
of valence electrons.
This is probably the easiest to
explain and to think about,
because if we have an odd number
that means that we
can't have our octet rule,
because our octet rule works
by pairing electrons.
And if we have an odd number,
we automatically have an odd
electron out.
So, if we look at an example,
the methyl radical, we can
first think about how we draw
the Lewis structure -- we draw
the skeletal structure here.
And then what we're going to
do is add up our valence
electrons -- we have 3 times 1
for the hydrogen atoms, carbon
has 4 valence electrons, so
we have a total of 7.
If we want to fill all of our
valence shells in each of
these atoms, we're going to need
a total of 14 electrons.
So, what we see we're
left with is that we
have 7 bonding electrons.
So we can fill in 6 of those
straightforward here, because
we know that we need to make
3 different bonds.
And now we're left over
with 1 electron, we
can't make a bond.
So, what we'll do is carbon does
not have an octet yet.
We can't get it one, but we
can do the best we can and
help it out with adding that
extra electron onto the carbon
atom, so that at least we're
getting as close as possible
to filling our octets.
This is what we call a radical
species or a free radical.
Free radical or radical species
is essentially any
type of a molecule that has this
unpaired electron on one
of the atoms. This might look
really strange, we're used to
seeing octets.
But you'll realize, if you
calculate the formal charge on
this molecule, that
it's not the worst
situation ever for carbon.
At least it's formal charge is
zero, even if it doesn't have
-- it would rather have
an extra bond
and have a full octet.
But it's not the worst scenario
that we can imagine.
But still, radicals tend to be
incredibly reactive because
they do want to fill
that octet.
So, what happens when you have a
radical is it tends to react
with the first thing that it
runs into, especially highly
reactive radicals that are not
stabilized in some other way,
which you'll tend to talk about
it organic chemistry --
how you can stabilize
radicals.
So the term free radical should
sound familiar to you,
whether you've heard it in
chemistry before, or you
haven't heard it in chemistry,
but maybe have heard it, I
don't know, commercials
for facial
products or other things.
People like to talk about free
radicals, and they're sort of
the hero that gets rid of
free radicals, which are
antioxidants.
So you hear in a lot of
different creams or products
or vitamins that they have
antioxidants in them, which
get rid of free radicals.
The reason you would want to
get rid of free radicals is
that free radicals can
damage DNA, so
they're incredibly reactive.
It makes sense that if they hit
a strand of DNA, they're
going to react with the DNA,
you end up breaking the
strands of DNA and causing
DNA damage.
So, this is actually what
happens in aging because we
have a lot of free radicals
in our body.
We can introduce them
artificially, for example,
cigarette smoke has a lot of
really dangerous free radicals
that get into the cells in your
lungs, which damage your
lung DNA, which can
cause lung cancer.
But also, all of us are living
and breathing, which means
we're having metabolism go on in
our body, which means that
as we use oxygen and as we
metabolize our food, we are
actually producing free
radicals as well.
So it's kind of a paradox
because we need them because
they are a natural by-product of
these important processes,
but then they can go on and
damage cells, which is what
kind of is causing aging
and can lead to cancer.
We have enzymes in our body
that repair damage that is
done by free radicals, that will
put the strands of DNA
back together.
And we also have antioxidants
in our body.
So, you might know that, for
example, very brightly colored
fruit is full of antioxidants,
they're full of chemicals that
will neutralize free radicals.
Lots of vitamins are also
antioxidants, so we have
vitamin A on the top there
and vitamin E.
So, the most common thing we
think of when we think of free
radicals is very reactive,
bad for your
body, causes DNA damage.
But the reality is that
free radicals are also
essential for life.
So this is kind of interesting
to think about.
And, for example, certain
enzymes or proteins actually
use free radicals in order to
carry out the reactions that
they carry out in your body.
So, for example, this is a
picture or a snapshot of a
protein, this is a crystal
structure of ribonucleotide
reductase is what it's called.
It's an enzyme that catalyzes
the reaction of an essential
step in both DNA synthesis and
also DNA repair, and it
requires having radicals within
its active site in
order to carry out
the chemistry.
So, this is kind of a neat
paradox, because radicals
damage DNA, but in order to
repair your DNA, you need
certain enzymes, and those
enzymes require different
types of free radicals.
So, free radicals are definitely
very interesting,
and once we get -- or hopefully
you will get into
organic chemistry at some point
and get to really think
about what they do in terms
of a radical mechanism.
We can think about radicals that
are also more stable, so
let's do another example with
the molecule nitric acid.
So we can again, draw the
skeleton here, and just by
looking at it we might not know
it's a radical, but as we
start to count valence
electrons, we should be able
to figure it out very quickly,
because what we have is 11
valence electrons.
We need 16 electrons to
have full octets.
So, we're left with 5
bonding electrons.
We put a double bond in between
our nitrogen and our
oxygen, so what we're left
over with is this single
bonding electron, and we'll put
that on the nitrogen here.
And I'll explain why we put it
on the nitrogen and not the
oxygen in just a minute.
But what we find is then once
we fill in the rest of the
valence electrons in terms of
lone pairs, this is the
structure that we get.
And if you add up all of the
formal charges on the nitrogen
and on the oxygen, what you'll
see is they're both 0.
So if you happen to try drawing
this structure and you
put the lone pair on oxygen and
then you figured out the
formal charge and saw that you
had a split charge, a plus 1
and a minus 1, the first thing
you might want to try is
putting it on the other atom,
and once you did that you'd
see that you had a
better structure
with no formal charge.
I have to mention what nitric
oxide does, because it's a
very interesting molecule.
Don't get it confused with
nitrous oxide, which is happy
gas, that's n o 2.
This is nitric oxide, and it's
actually much more interesting
than nitrous oxide.
It's a signaling molecule in
your body, it's one of the
very few signaling molecules
that is a gas, and obviously,
it's also a radical.
What happens with n o is that
it's produced in the
endothelium of your blood
vessels, so the inner lining
of your blood vessels, and it
signals for smooth muscle that
line your blood vessels
to relax, which causes
vasodilation , and by
vasodilation, I just mean a
widening of the blood vessels.
So, n o signals for your blood
vessels to get wider and allow
more blood to flow through.
And if you think about what
consequences this could have,
in terms of places where they
have high altitude, so they
have lower oxygen levels, do
you think that they produce
more or less and
n o their body?
More?
Yeah, it turns out they
do produce more.
The reason they produce more is
that they want to have more
blood flowing through their
veins so that they can get
more oxygenated blood into
different parts of their body.
N o is also a target in the
pharmaceutical industry.
A very famous one that became
famous I guess over 10 years
ago now, and this is from a drug
that actually targets one
of n o's receptors, and this
drug has the net effect of
vasodilation or widening of
blood vessels in a certain
area in the body.
So this is viagra, some of you
may be familiar, I think
everyone's heard of viagra.
Now you know how viagra works.
Viagra breaks down, or it
inhibits the breakdown of n
o's binding partner in just
certain areas, not everywhere
in your body.
So, in those areas, what happens
is you get more n o
signaling, you get more
vasodilation, you get
increased blood flow.
So that's a little bit
of pharmacology
for you here today.
All right, so let's talk about
one more example in terms of
the breakdown of the octet
rule with radicals.
Let's think about molecular
oxygen.
So let's go ahead and quickly
draw this Lewis structure.
We have o 2.
The second thing we
need to do is
figure out valence electrons.
6 plus 6, so we would
expect to see 12.
For a complete octet we would
need 8 electrons each, so 16.
So in terms of bonding
electrons, what we have is 4
bonding electrons.
So, we can go ahead and fill
those in as a double bond
between the two oxygens.
So, what we end up having left,
and this would be step
six then because five was just
filling in that, is 12 minus
4, so we have 8 lone pair
electrons left.
So we can just fill it in to
our oxygens like this.
All right, so using everything
we've learned about Lewis
structures, we here have the
structure of molecular oxygen.
And I just want to point out for
anyone that gets confused,
when we talk about oxygen as
an atom, that's o, but
molecular oxygen is actually
o 2, the same for molecular
hydrogen, for example.
All right, so let's look at
what the actual Lewis
structure is for molecular
oxygen, and it turns out that
actually we don't have a double
bond, we have a single
bond, and we have
two radicals.
And any time we have two
radicals, we talk about what's
called a biradical.
And while using this exception
to the Lewis structure rule,
to the octet rule for odd
numbers of valence electrons
can clue us into the fact that
we have a radical, there's
really no way for us to use
Lewis structures to predict
when we have a biradical, right,
because we would just
predict that we would get this
Lewis structure here.
So, when I first introduced
Lewis structures, I said these
are great, they're really easy
to use and they work about 90%
of the time.
This falls into that 10%
that Lewis structures
don't work for us.
It turns out, in order to
understand that this is the
electron configuration for o
2, we need to use something
called molecular orbital theory,
and just wait till
next Wednesday and we will tell
you what that is, and we
will, in fact, use
it for oxygen.
But until that point, I'll just
tell you that molecular
orbital theory takes into
account quantum mechanics,
which Lewis theory does not.
So that's why, in fact, there
are those 10% of cases that
Lewis structures
don't work for.
All right, the second case of
exceptions to the octet rule
are when we have octet
deficient molecules.
So basically, this means we're
going to have a molecule
that's stable, even though it
doesn't have a complete octet.
And these tend to happen in
group 13 molecules, and
actually happen almost
exclusively in group 13
molecules, specifically with
boron and aluminum.
So, any time you see a Lewis
structure with boron or
aluminum, you want to just
remember that I should look
out to make sure that these
might have an incomplete
octet, so look out for that
when you see those atoms.
So, let's look at b f 3
as our example here.
And what we see for b f 3
is the number of valence
electrons that we have are 24,
because the valence number of
electrons for boron
is 3, and then 3
times 7 for each fluorine.
For total filled octets we need
32, so that means we need
8 bonding electrons.
So, let's assign two to each
bond here, and then we're
going to have two extra bonding
electrons, so let's
just arbitrarily pick
a fluorine to give
a double bond to.
And then we can fill in the lone
pair electrons, we have
16 left over.
So thinking about what the
formal charge is, if we want
to figure out the formal charge
for the boron here,
what we're talking about is the
valence number for boron,
which is 3, minus 0 because
there are no lone pairs, minus
1/2 of 8 because there are
eight shared electrons.
We get a formal charge
of minus 1.
What is our formal charge
since we learned this on
Monday for thinking
about the double
bonded fluorine in boron?
So, look at your notes and look
at the fluorine that has
a double bond with it, and I
want you to go ahead and tell
me what that formal
charge should be.
All right, let's take 10
more seconds on that.
OK, so 49%.
So, let's go look back at the
notes, we'll talk about why
about 50% of you are right, and
50% need to review, which
I totally understand you haven't
had time to do yet,
your formal charge rules from
Monday's class, there were
other things going on.
But let's talk about how we
figure out formal charge.
Formal charge is just the number
of valence electrons
you have. So fluorine has 7.
You should be able to look at a
periodic table and see that
fluorine has seven.
What we subtract from that is
the number of lone pair
electrons, and there are four
lone pair electrons on this
double bonded fluorine,
so it's minus 4.
Then we subtract 1/2 of
the shared electrons.
Well we have a double bond with
boron here, so we have a
total of 4 shared electrons.
And when we do the subtraction
here, what we end up with is a
formal charge plus 1 on the
double bonded fluorine.
Without even doing a
calculation, what do you think
that the formal charge
should be on you
single bonded fluorines?
Good.
OK, it should be
0 and it is 0.
The reason it's zero in terms of
calculating it is 7 minus 6
lone pair electrons minus
1/2 half of 2 shared
electrons is 0.
The reason that you all told
me, I think, and I hope, is
that you know that the formal
charge on individual atoms has
to equal the total charge
on the molecule.
So if we already have a minus 1
and a plus 1, and we know we
have no charge in the molecule,
and we only have one
type of atom left to talk about,
that formal charge had
better be 0.
OK.
So this looks pretty good in
terms of a Lewis structure, we
figured out our formal
charges.
These also look pretty good,
too, we don't have too much
charge separation.
But what actually it turns out
is that if you experimentally
look at what type of bonds you
have, it turns out that all
three of the b f bonds are equal
in length, and they all
have a length that would
correspond to a single bond.
So, experimentally, we know we
have to throw out this Lewis
structure here, we have some
more information, let's think
about how this could happen.
So this could happen, for
example, is if we take this
two of the electrons that are in
the b f double bond and we
put it right on to the fluorine
here, so now we have
all single bonds.
And let's think about what the
formal charge situation would
be in this case here.
What happens here is now we
would have a formal charge of
0 on the boron, we'd have a
formal charge of 0 on all of
the fluorine molecules
as well.
So, it turns out that actually
looking at formal charge, even
though the first case didn't
look too bad, this case
actually looks a lot better.
We have absolutely no formal
charge separation whatsoever.
It turns out again, boron and
aluminum, those are the two
that you want to look out for.
They can be perfectly happy
without a full octet, they're
perfectly happy with 6 instead
of 8 in terms of electrons in
their valence shell.
So that is our exception
the number two.
We have one more exception and
this is a valence shell
expansion, and this can be the
hardest to look out for,
students tend to forget to look
for this one, but it's
very important as well, because
there are a lot of
structures that are affected
for this .
And this is only applicable if
we're talking about a central
atom that has an n value or
a principle quantum number
that's equal to or greater
than three.
What happens when we have n
that's equal to or greater to
three, is that now, in addition
to s orbitals and p
orbitals, what else do we
have available to us?
D orbitals, great.
So what we see is we have some
empty d orbitals, which means
that we can have more than
eight electrons that fit
around that central atom.
If you're looking to see if this
is going to happen, do
you think this would happen
with a large or
small central atom?
So think of it in terms
of just fitting.
We've got to fit more than
8 electrons around here.
Yeah, so it's going to be, we
need to have a large central
atom in order for this
to take place.
Literally, we just need to fit
everything around is probably
the easiest way to
think about it.
And what happens is it also
tends to have small atoms that
it's bonded to.
Again, just think of it in terms
of all fitting in there.
So, let's take an
example p c l 5.
The first example is the more
straightforward example,
because let's start to draw the
Lewis structure, and what
we see is that phosphorous has
five chlorines around it.
So we already know if we want
to form five bonds we've
broken our octet rule.
But let's go through and figure
this out and see how
that happens.
What we know is we need
40 valence electrons,
we have those --
5 from the phosphorous, and
we have 7 from each of the
chlorine atoms. If we were to
fill out all of those octets,
that would be 48 electrons.
So what we end up with when
we do our Lewis structure
calculation is that we only
have 8 bonding electrons
available to us.
So we can fill those in between
the phosphorous and
the chlorine, those 8
bonding electrons.
So, this is obviously
a problem.
To make 5 p c l bonds we need
10 shared electrons, and we
know that that's the situation
because it's called p c l 5
and not p c l 4, so we can go
right ahead and add in that
extra electron pair.
So we've used up 10 for bonding,
so that means what we
have left is 30 lone pair
electrons, and I would not
recommend filling all of these
in your notes right now, you
can go back and do that, but
just know the rest end up
filling up the octets for
all of the chlorines.
So, in this first case where you
actually need to make more
than for bonds, you will
immediately know you need to
use this exception to the Lewis
structure octet rule,
but sometimes it won't
be as obvious.
So, let's look at c r o 4, the
2 minus version here, so a
chromate ion, and if we draw
the skeletal structure, we
have four things that the
chromate needs to bond to.
So, let's do the Lewis
structure again.
When we figure out the valence
electrons, we have total, we
have 6 from the chromium, we
have 6 from each of the
different oxygens, and where
did this 2 come from?
Yup, the negative charge.
So, remember, we have 2 extra
electrons hanging out in our
molecule, so we need
to include those.
We have a total of 32.
40 are needed to
fill up octets.
So again, we have 8 bonding
electrons available, so we can
go ahead and fill these in
between each of the bonds.
What happens is that we then
have 24 lone pair electrons
left, and we can fill
those in like this.
And the problem comes
now when we figure
out the formal charge.
So, when we do that what we find
is that the chromium has
a formal charge of plus 1, and
that each of the oxygens has a
total charge of minus 1.
So we actually have a bit of
charge separation here.
Without even doing a
calculation, what is the total
charge of these that
are added up?
OK, it's minus 2,
that's right.
We know that the total charge of
each of the formal charges
has to add up to minus 2,
because that's the charge in
our molecule.
We can also just calculate it
-- the chromate gives us a
plus 2, then we have 4 times
minus 1 for each of the
oxygens, so we have a minus 2.
So, we have some charge
separation here, and in some
cases, if we're not at n equals
3 or higher, there's
really nothing we can do about
it, this would be the best
structure we can do.
But since we have these d
orbitals available, we can use
them, and it turns out that
experimentally this is what's
found, that the length and the
strength are not single bonds,
but they're actually something
between a single bond and a
double bond.
So how do we get a 1 and 1/2
bond, for example, what's the
term that let's us do that?
Resonance.
That's right.
So that's exactly what's
happening here.
So, if we went ahead and drew
this structure here where we
have now two double bonds and
two single bonds, that would
be in resonance with another
structure where we have two
double bonds instead to these
two oxygens, and now, single
bonds to these two oxygens.
We can actually also have
several other resonance
structures as well.
Remember, the definition of a
resonance structure is where
all the atoms stay the same,
but what we can do is move
around the electrons -- we're
moving around those extra two
electrons that can be
in double bonds.
So, why don't you tell me
how many other resonance
structures you would expect to
see for this chromate ion?
All right, let's take 10
more seconds on this.
All right.
This is good.
I know this is a real split
response, but the right answer
is the one that is indicated
in the graph
here that it's four.
This takes a little bit of time
to get used to thinking
about all the different Lewis
structures you can have. So,
you guys should all go back
home if you can't see it
immediately right now and try
drawing out those four other
Lewis structures, for chromate,
there are four others.
You'll probably get a chance to
literally do this example
in recitation where you draw
out all four, but it's even
better to make sure you
understand it before you get
to that point.
So, we can go back to
the class notes.
So it turns out there's four
other Lewis structures, so
basically just think about
all the other different
combinations where you can have
single and double bonds,
and when you draw those out,
you end up with four.
So, for every single one of
these Lewis structures, we
could figure out what the formal
charges are, and what
we would find is that it's 0
on the chromium, it's 0 for
the double bonded oxygens, and
it's going to be negative 1
for the single bonded oxygens.
So, what you can see is that in
this situation, we end up
having less formal charge
separation, and that's what
we're looking for, that's the
more stable structure.
So any time you can have an
expanded octet -- an expanded
valence shell, where you have n
is equal to or greater than
3, and by expanding and adding
more electrons into that
valence shell, you lower
the charge separation,
you want to do that.
I also want to point out, I
basically said there's 6
different ways we can draw this
in terms of drawing all
the resonance structures.
You might be wondering if you
have to figure out the formal
charge for each structure
individually, and the answer
is no, you can pick any single
structure and the formal
charges will work
out the same.
So, for example, if you pick
this structure and your friend
picks this structure, you'll
both get the right answer that
there's just the negative 1 on
the oxygens and no other
formal charges in the molecule.
All right.
So those are the end of our
exceptions to the octet rule
for Lewis structures, that's
everything we're going to say
about Lewis structures.
And remember, that when we talk
about Lewis structures,
what they tell us is the
electron configuration in
covalent bonds, so that
valence shell electron
configuration.
So we talked a lot about
covalent bonds before we got
into Lewis structures, and then
how to represent covalent
bonds by Lewis structures.
So now I'll say a little bit
about ionic bonds, which are
the other extreme, and when you
have an ionic bond, what
you have now is a complete
transfer of either one or many
electrons between two atoms. So
the key word for covalent
bond was electron sharing, the
key word for ionic bonds is
electron transfer.
And the bonding between the two
atoms ends up resulting
from an attraction that we're
very familiar with, which is
the Coulomb or the electrostatic
attraction
between the negatively
charged and the
positively charged ions.
So let's take an example.
The easiest one to think about
is where we have a negative 1
and a positive 1 ion.
So this is salt, n a c l --
actually lots of things are
call salt, but this is what
we think of a table salt.
So, let's think about what we
have to do if we want the form
sodium chloride from the neutral
sodium and chlorine
atoms. So, the first thing that
we're going to need to do
is we need to convert sodium
into sodium plus.
What does this process
look like to you?
Is this one of those periodic
trends, perhaps?
Can anyone name what we're
looking at here?
Exactly, ionization energy.
So, if we're going to talk about
the energy difference
here, what we're going to
be talking about is the
ionization energy, or the energy
it takes to rip off an
electron from sodium in order
to form the sodium plus ion.
So, we can just put right
here, that's 494
kilojoules per mole.
The next thing that we want to
look at is chlorine, so in
terms of chlorine we need to
go to chlorine minus, so we
actually need to add
an electron.
This is actually the reverse of
one of the periodic trends
we talked about.
Which trend is that this
is the reverse of?
Electron affinity, right.
Because if we go backwards we're
saying how badly does
chlorine want to grab
an electron?
Chlorine wants to do this very
badly, and it turns out the
electron affinity for chlorine
is huge, it's 349 kilojoules
per mole, but remember, we're
going in reverse, so we need
to talk about it as negative
349 kilojoules per mole.
So if we talk about the sum of
what's happening here, what we
need to do is think about going
from the neutrals to the
ions, so we can just add those
two energies together, and
what we end up with is plus 145
kilojoules per mole, in
order to go from neutral
sodium in
chlorine to the ions.
So, the problem here is that we
have to actually put energy
into our system, so this doesn't
seem favorable, right.
What's favorable is when we
actually get energy out and
our energy gets lower, but what
we're saying here is that
we actually need to
put in energy.
So another way to say
this is this process
actually requires energy.
It does not emit energy, it
does not give off excess
energy, it requires energy.
So, we need to think about how
can we solve this problem in
terms of thinking about ionic
bonds, and the answer is
Coulomb attraction.
So there's one more force that
we need to talk about, and
that is when we talk about the
attraction between the
negatively and the positively
charged ions, such that we
form sodium chloride.
So this process here has a
delta energy, a change in
energy of negative 589
kilojoules per mole.
So that's huge, we're giving
off a lot of energy by this
attraction.
So if we add up the net energy
for all of this process, all
we need to do is add negative
589 to plus 145.
So what we end up getting is the
net energy change is going
to be negative 444 kilojoules
per mole, so you can see that,
in fact, it is very favorable
for neutral sodium and neutral
chloride to form sodium chloride
in an ionic bond.
And the net increase then,
is a decrease in energy.
So, I just gave you the number
in terms of what that Coulomb
potential would be in
attraction, but we can I
easily calculate it as well
using this equation here where
the energy is equal to the
charge on each of the ions,
and this is just multiplied by
the value of charge for an
electron divided by 4 pi epsilon
nought times r, are r
is just the distance in terms
of the bond length we could
talk about.
So, let's calculate and make
sure that I didn't tell you a
false number here.
Let's say we do the calculation
with the bond
length that we've looked
up, which is 2 .
3 6 angstroms for
the bond length
between sodium and chloride.
So we should be able to figure
out the Coulombic
attraction for this.
So, if we talk about the energy
of attraction, we need
to multiply plus 1, that's the
charge on the sodium, times
minus 1, the charge on the
chlorine, times the charge in
an electron, 1 .
6 0 2 times 10 the negative 19
Coulombs, and that's all
divided by 4 pi, and then I've
written out epsilon nought in
your notes, so I won't write
it on the board.
And then r, so r is
going to be 2 .
3 6 and times -- what is
angstrom, everyone?
Yup, 10 to the negative 10.
So 10 to the negative
10 meters.
So, if we do this calculation
here, what we end up with is
negative 9.774 times 10 to
the negative 19 joules.
So that's what we have in
terms of our energy.
That does not look the same as
what we saw -- yup, do you
have a question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Luckily, although, I did not
write it in my own notes, I
did it when I put in my
calculator, thank you.
So you need to square this value
here and then you should
get this value right here,
negative 9.77.
All right, so what we need to
do though is convert from
joules into kilojoules per mole,
because that's what we
were using.
So if we multiply that number
there by kilojoules per mole
-- or excuse me, first
kilojoules per joule, so we
have 1,000 joules in
every kilojoule.
And then we multiply that by
Avagadro's number, 6.022 times
10 to the 23 per mole.
What we end up with
is negative 589
kilojoules per mole.
So this is that same Coulombic
attraction that we saw in the
first place.
So, notice that you will
naturally get out a negative
charge here, remember negative
means an attractive force in
this case, because you
have the plus and
the minus 1 in here.
So we should be able to easily
do that calculation, and what
we end up getting matches up
with what I just told you,
luckily, and thank you for
catching the square, that's an
important part in getting
the right answer.
So, experimentally then, what we
find is that the change in
energy for this reaction
is negative 444
kilojoules per mole.
If we look experimentally what
we see, it's actually a little
bit different, it's negative
411 kilojoules per mole.
So, in terms of this class, this
is the method that we're
going to use, and we're going
to say this gets us close
enough such that we can make
comparisons and have a
meaningful conversations about
different types of ionic bonds
and the attraction
between them.
But let's think about where this
discrepancy comes from,
and before I do that I want to
point out, one term we use a
lot is change in energy for a
reaction where, for example,
you break a bond.
Remember that the negative of
the change in energy is what's
called delta e sub d.
We first saw this when we first
introduced the idea of
covalent bonds.
Do you remember what this term
here means, delta e sub d?
A little bit and some no's,
which this was pre-exam, I
understand, you still need to
review those notes, it's
dissociation energy.
So you get a negative energy
out by breaking the bond.
The dissociation energy means
how much energy that bond is
worth in terms of strength, so
it's the opposite of the
energy you get out of breaking
the bond -- or excuse me, the
energy that you get out
of forming the bond.
It's the amount of energy you
need to put in to break the
bond is dissociation energy.
It takes this much energy
to dissociate your
bond, excuse me.
All right.
So, let's take a look here at
our predictions, so I just put
them both ways so we
don't get confused.
The dissociation
energy is 444.
The change in energy
for forming the
bond is negative 444.
We made the following
approximations, which explain
why, in fact, we got a different
experimental energy,
if we look at that.
The first thing is that we
ignored any repulsive
interactions.
If you think about salt, it's
not just two single atoms that
you are talking about.
It's actually in a whole network
or whole lattice of
other molecules, so you actually
have some other
chlorines around that are going
to be having repulsive
interactions with our chlorine
that we're talking about.
We're going to ignore those,
make the approximation that
those don't matter, at this
point, in these calculations.
And the result for that is that
we end up with a larger
dissociation energy than
the experimental value.
That's because the bond is going
to be a little bit more
broken than it was in our
calculation, because we do
have these repulsive
interactions.
The other thing that we did is
that we treated both sodium
and the chlorine as
point charges.
And this is what actually
allowed us to make this
calculation and calculate the
Coulomb potential so easily,
we just treated them as if
they're point charges.
We're ignoring quantum mechanics
in this -- this is
sort of the class where we
ignore quantum mechanics, we
ignored it for Lewis
structures,
we're ignoring it here.
We will be back to paying a lot
of attention to quantum
mechanics in lecture 14 when we
talk about MO theory, but
for now, these are
approximations, these are
models where we don't take
it into consideration.
And I think you'll agree that we
come reasonably close such
that we'll be able to make
comparisons between different
kinds of ionic bonds.
All right.
So, the last thing I want to
introduce today is talking
about polar covalent bonds.
We've now covered the
two extremes.
One extreme is complete total
electron sharing -- if we have
a perfectly covalent bond,
we have perfect sharing.
The other is electron transfer
in terms of ionic bonds.
So when we talk about a polar
covalent bond, what we're now
talking about is an unequal
sharing of electrons between
two atoms.
So, this is essentially
something we've seen before,
we just never formally talked
about what we would call it.
This is any time you have a
bond forming between two
non-metals that have different
electronegativities, so, for
example, hydrogen
choride, h c l.
The electronegativity for
hydrogen is 2.2, for
chlorine it's 3.2.
And in general, what we say is
we consider a difference in
terms of a first approximation
if the difference in
electronegativity
is more than 0.
5, so this is on the Pauling
electronegativity scale.
So what we end up having is we
sort of have a kind of, and
what we call it is a partial
negative charge on the
chlorine, and a partial
positive
charge in the hydrogen.
The reason we have that is
because the chlorine's more
electronegative, it wants to
pull more of that shared
electron density to itself.
If it has more electron density,
it's going to have a
little bit of a negative charge
and the hydrogen's
going to be left with a little
bit of a positive charge.
So, we can compare this, for
example to, molecular hydrogen
where they're going to have
that complete sharing, so
there's not going to be a delta
plus or a delta minus,
delta is going to be equal to
zero on each of the atoms.
They are completely sharing
their electrons.
And we can also explain this
in another way by talking
about a dipole moment where we
have a charged distribution
that results in this dipole,
this electric dipole.
And we talk about this using
the term mu, which is a
measurement of what
the dipole is.
A dipole is always written in
terms of writing an arrow from
the positive charge to
the negative charge.
In chemistry, we are always
incredibly interested in what
the electrons are doing, so we
tend to pay attention to them
in terms of arrows.
Oh, the electrons are going over
to the chlorine, so we're
going to draw our arrow toward
the chlorine atom.
So, we measure this here, so mu
is equal to q times r, the
distance between the two.
And q, that charge is just equal
to the partial negative
or the partial positive times
the charge on the electron.
So this is measured in Coulomb
meters, you won't ever see a
measurement of electronegativity
in Coulomb
meters -- we tend to talk about
it in terms of debye or
1 d, or sometimes there's no
units at all, so the d is just
assumed, and it's because 1
debye is just equal to this
very tiny number of Coulomb
meters and it's a lot easier
to work with debye's here.
So, when we talk about polar
molecules, we can actually
extend our idea of talking about
polar bonds to talking
about polar molecules.
So, actually let's start
with that on Monday.
So everyone have a
great weekend.